die karikatur des kapitalisten
disney-star coebad druck von wegen
die echten superreichen scheffeln geld
ohne großes zutun
ihr reichtum vermehrt sich quasi von
alleine während die allgemeine
wirtschaft stagniert oder nur minimal
wächst linke propaganda nein
den beleg für die ausufernde
ungleichheit gibt es jetzt
wissenschaftlich untermauert im dicken
wälzer das kapital im 21 jahrhundert
diese analyse ist an der pariser
universität entstanden im ökonomischen
institut
15 jahre lang hat professor doom appétit
mit kollegen daten über vermögen und
einkommen aus 20 ländern gesammelt und
analysiert
sein fazit alarmiert
in den letzten jahrzehnten sind die
gewinne aus großen vermögen in den usa
aber auch in europa um ein vielfaches
stärker gewachsen als der durchschnitt
und das wichtigste ergebnis meiner
untersuchung
es gibt einfach keine natürlichen kräfte
die garantie an das ganze in einem
vernünftigen rahmen zu halten
kultur ist saisonal er konstatiert eine
gigantische vermögenskonzentration auch
wenn die fachwelt an seine arbeiter rom
mäkelt er hat recht meint
wirtschaftsprofessor klaus wellershoff
ehemaliger chefökonom der ubs bestimmt
kein linker die entwicklung die partie
beschreibt sind von einer solchen
größenordnung von waffengewalt
eigentlich würden sich das genauer vor
augen führt dass man das zwar marginal
kritisieren kann und wahrscheinlich ist
nicht alles genau so wie es in den
tabellen zu finden ist aber die
grundaussagen glaube ich bleiben
bestehen
die botschaft schlägt ein die englische
ausgabe seiner nüchternen studie ist ein
bestseller in der angelsächsischen welt
und er der wirtschaftsanalytiker eine
art messias seit monaten reiste er von
auftritt zu auftritt aller kanäle
verbreiten pittis brisante analyse die
bbc bietet sogar nachhilfeunterricht
kapital besteht aus sachanlagen und
immobilien grundstücken wertpapieren und
kurt haben all das wächst dank rendite
mieteinnahmen dividenden zinsen würden
alle gewinne reinvestiert gäbe es ein
wirtschaftswachstum für die ganze
gesellschaft auch die einfachen
arbeitnehmenden könnten einkommen und
vermögen steigern
doch die gt weiß nach die reichen
spekulieren mit ihrem kapital lieber an
den finanzmärkten und fahren riesige
gewinne ein
vieles davon steuerfrei deshalb ist
deren vermögenszuwachs viel größer als
das allgemeine wirtschaftswachstum
die folge immer weniger menschen
besitzen immer mehr kapital
der neoliberalismus seit ende der 70er
jahre
macht's möglich pittis paradebeispiel
lilian beton co l'oreal erbin
sie verdoppelte ihr vermögen in rund
zehn jahren auf mittlerweile 30
milliarden dollar
vor allem dank finanzspekulation überall
dasselbe bild
auch hierzulande das reichste eine
prozent der schweizer bevölkerung
besitzt so viel wie die anderen 99
prozent zusammen und diese ungleichheit
verschärft sich nicht zuletzt durch
vererbung
das ist ein bruch mit der idee der
leistungsgesellschaft
das schafft ungleichheit in einer ganz
neuen dimension
das ist ja die große gesellschaftliche
frage die da drin steckt ob ererbtes
vermögen in der langen frist
letztendlich die gesellschaft dominieren
sollte und damit auch die politik und an
unsere entscheidung die 99% begehren auf
besonders in den usa
werte wie chancengleichheit und
mitbestimmung scheinen ihnen hohe wie
kitty ist ihr neuer prophetie ist einer
der wenigen ökonomen der letzten zwanzig
dreißig jahre der sich traut tatsächlich
auch eine politische stellung zu
beziehen und die gesellschaftliche
relevanz des themas zu beleuchten als
erstes fordert der streitbare ökonom
umfassende informationen über die
kapitalströme dieser welt viel mehr
transparenz bei allen finanz bewegung
globaler informationsaustausch wir
wissen ja gar nicht wer was besitzt oder
konten in der schweiz und anderen
ländern hat und gegen die
diagnostizierte gefahr mächtiger erb
dynastien verschreibt p gt die globex
eine weltweite ächtung steuer das alles
ist nicht bloß ein frommer wunsch
prophezeit klaus wellershoff
das ist eine reale diskussion und sie
wird noch viel realer als sich die
menschen das heute vorstellen können
durch die tendenz zu überwachungsstaat
die wir feststellen wir haben immer mehr
transparenz über einkommens und
vermögens bewegung und damit schrumpft
die fähigkeit der besteuerung
auszuweichen auf praktisch null
gläserne bürger und überwachungsstaat
also als preis für soziale gerechtigkeit
keine schöne aber wohl die realistische
alternative zur herrschaft der
multimilliardär